there are so many nights where I would
remember uh the EM the engagement
manager would say to me that this is a
priority that you must finish before
tomorrow so that's why typically we work
12 to 15 hour days or even more so let's
talk about that when everything becoming
a property so yes for sure this does
happen so someone pushing you to still
not in the evening maybe even at night
complete something for the next day I
think if you're quite Junior in your
first half year or in your first year
you feel like University to do
everything that you're being asked to do
right everything just say yes of course
I need to do this and so on even though
this means really working really late
there are some tips and tricks and
techniques that can just pick up over
time to manage this in a bit better way
for you